the Milky Way has passed and the whole
story leads us to where we are now and
who we are now so what created the Milky
Way and how did it grow into the
majestic galaxies we see today
to answer that we have to travel back to
the infant universe to just after the
Big Bang thirteen point six billion
years ago there are no stars no planets
and no galaxies
how do we go from that early universe
that's almost perfectly perfectly
featureless to this complex and very
interesting universe that we see around
us today the early universe is a thick
uniform soup of gas with some tiny
irregularities but it's enough to set
gravity to work pulling gas together
gravity keeps on compressing the gas
down to a point
and that's when temperatures rise
dramatically to fifty to a hundred
million degrees at that point you get
ignition at that point hydrogen fuses
into helium and we get a star a star is
born
in this theory not one but millions of
stars burst into life slowly gravity
brings them together after a few million
years they form a rotating sphere of
stars and a galaxy is born there's a
problem though
there's too much gravity something other
than just the Stars must be holding them
together but what is it turns out the
answer lies at the center of our own
galaxy
at the very heart of the Milky Way you
see stars orbiting something that isn't
there and if you do the calculations the
amount of mass needed at the very center
is about 4 million times the mass of our
Sun so stars are basically orbiting like
planets around this empty object with 4
million times the mass of the Sun this
object must be colossal it must be
unimaginably dense it could only be one
thing a black hole a supermassive black
hole
if the moon goes around the earth and
the earth goes around the Sun then what
does the Sun go around
the Sun goes around a massive black hole
at the center of the galaxy within the
Milky Way scientists find their first
supermassive black hole but it wasn't
the last turns out there everywhere